first up he is the Iraq war
correspondent who wrote and directed the
new documentary only the dead seen the
end of war airing on HBO
starting March 28th Michael where is
black with us Michael I see you in the
car mama singing the time all right how
are you Michael always good to see you
oh my god it's been many lives in death
since we saw each other words and now
we're living in a Trump nation so you
know what do we do with ourselves were
you from Australia
further as part of the planet you can
possibly imagine
so right now it's the metro those
[ __ ] Australians are taking over and
we're not going away
I can we're doing it very [ __ ]
quietly you step out okay all right so I
watched your movie I got a scream sorry
for that stop touching me and I know he
acts cool get all right good
I know seven years in Iraq it gets
lonely uh-huh it gets very very lonely
deserts are very dark and lonely lord
knows you cannot hit on the local chest
Hey yeah that would not do that dosnt
yes it's the three blocks I know who did
that it all ended up dead so that's a
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah not [ __ ] anyway
moving right along
no let's talk about this oh yeah that
takes a lot of balls in a Muslim pantry
and you'll lose them too
right yeah all right so but your movie
is I feel it's gonna be the feel-good
hit of the summer it's the wrong calm
that everyone's got it's a date movie no
it's a it's really [ __ ] you can only
gotcha I'll tell you because you shot
over 250 hours on their own little
camera when you're in Iraq yeah and this
is really about the birth of Isis and
Zarqawi and all that and before let's go
back a little before that because before
there was our car we there was the
insurgency which yeah something
different America kicked over Saddam
Hussein and then there's a very
interesting scene where you show there's
a point where an American soldier fires
into a car at a checkpoint in rocky
a kid a kid you see the Iraqis brother
yeah who is in the car with him very
emotional saying America you're gonna
pay yeah and I thought there's your
insurgency right there well that's
exactly right
I mean it was almost at the point and
and to the military's credit they knew
this it's almost fair for every one
person we killed or captured we create
we actually created two or three of
course new or more insurgents I mean we
were almost in a no-win situation and
the incident you're talking about
there's two kids two brothers one like
seventeen and ones like 15
they were driving through our
neighborhood where Time magazine lived
to get the family's monthly food ration
it just so happens that there was an
American raid going on hunting for
Saddam that obviously didn't find him
and some nervous
gi lights up their car and so this
fifteen-year-old watches his 17 year old
brothers brains blown away room and I
was there shortly thereafter and it just
so happened I stumbled on the kid's
funeral the next day and that's what you
see we can't relate to that well that's
a universal but that's a universe one of
it I know but that's a universal pain
of course we can all relate to that and
I know I think I forgot American room I
mean I can relate to that more than than
anyone else but we can all relate to
that kind of universal pain okay so when
you seed the way some politicians in
this country talk about what we should
do now I mean if you watch the
Republican debates they all talk about
how you know what we got to do with Isis
we gotta get put boots on the ground
they all want to go back in there and
you know we're gonna do it quick we're
gonna wipe him out and come home yeah we
couldn't do it quick when we had 150,000
I know it seems insane that the nanny
Jie this country has about its recent
past the Russians pulled out of Syria
this week how come we're the only
country that can't ever [ __ ] leave a
place Putin gets it I'm sorry
curtain guys get it um you're very good
at Quagmire's um what what will we write
what what nine one of us I pot head one
is if is an Iraq war veteran yeah this
conversation could go sideways very
easily
pick the toka no I was actually pausing
for a minute because what I was thinking
about was it was to your point I know
what all of this sabre-rattling and and
all of this adventurism shaves away from
the souls of your children I've seen it
man it's in your movie yeah if our film
says nothing else it's it's not just to
remind you all of that because you know
you've been told but there's no way you
can know what we hope of it is that if
you give us 78 minutes of your lives
with this movie there will be one moment
for all of you in this film where you
will be in Iraq and you'll see what it
took from your children from your
Marines from your soldiers because it's
it's it's more than the physical it's
about that place in the head in the
heart that you have to go to and we hope
that we actually transport you this is
not a film that you watch we want this
to be a film that you experience because
you know what almost 3.3 million of your
children have experienced something like
this you know what it reminded me of was
Apocalypse Now the way you talk about
Zarqawi who is the guy who as you say
accurately hijacked the insurgency and
the insurgency wasn't really a religious
war I had nothing to do right currently
he hijacked this and this is the
forbearer of Isis well there's no no
this is Isis let's not forget one of the
darkest legacies of our invasion and I
say our cost rally awaz a part of that
in Britain was a part of that we're the
West the darkest legacy of our invasion
of Iraq is that unwittingly we unleash
the Islamic state upon ourselves a plan
upon the rest of the world and that's
just a fact
right and what it takes to reach out and
touch that darkness even to combat it
you will see in this film and it's funny
you mention Apocalypse Now because you
know I had 300 like Kurt's while we're
trying to find this mythical figure
who's been in the jungle too long and
has gone crazy well it is bringing
craziness to the whole country hostile
you know it's and look but what about
you are you better now you don't know
you don't seem like you're quite as
crazy as you used to be oh the bathroom
tight guys [ __ ] yourself but thank you
brother now look do you sleep okay yeah
I actually sleep now I went for over a
decade where I didn't root and like many
your veterans some of them are still
struggling too some of them have have
done what I've done but you know I
finally made it home right now home will
never be the same again for the rest of
my life to the day I die I will walk
with ghosts but you know what that's a
privilege and I found a way to live with
that and some days that makes life
better and some days that makes life
harder but I have found my way home and
if I can share that in a piece of film
that last 78 minutes on your TV screens
and you know what Michael
maybe some of those guys to work ladies
he's on Christian mingle
welcome on Michael is always great
you